now if you're thin and scrawny is a
bigger cue your gal won't tumble let me
tell you what to do don't mope in the
corner don't think she's out of reach
just get up right and early and get out
to Muscle Beach swing on those high bars
it ain't hard why it's easy just like
shootin fish if you're a backward boy or
the apple of the eye of a pair of doting
parents by never-say-die don't stuff
your gut with soft marshmallow just
tackle those high bars like a real epic
film make like an athlete cut those
apron strings starve on your own get out
in the beach and just roll over it's a
clear day it's any day
in the summertime
in the summertime when the warm ol Sun
breaks through to you and you find
friends everywhere and the battered old
world seems new to you and your realize
with surprise that your eyes aren't
deceiving you come with me cuz the Seas
blue and free it's a clear day
a fantastic day in the summertime
the summertime
yep all kidding aside if it's Sun you
want if its ease of mind you want
feeling fit you want its Muscle Beach is
the thing for you you just lay around
and I'll sing for you watch the seagulls
eat hot dogs get a bellyache
now come and take it easy just take it
very easy cuz it's the summertime it's a
time to take it nice and easy or if your
body beautiful is bursting at the seams
in the docs prescription says they offer
custard creams and custard creams are
what you crave and reach for don't give
up the ship coz what is Muscle Beach for
reduce it take it off where it counts
now just take a look at these lads and
get a load of these gals like melodious
birds singing magic hands
they don't need padded shoulders and
they don't need Brussels cuz I got their
own foundations just building muscles
get that glorious lift they talked about
that smooth unbroken sweep accentuate
and minimize
a glamorous new you a little meditation
some idle contemplation cuz it's a
summer time it's a time to take it nice
and easy cuz it is in clothes that make
a man and it isn't money that makes a
man to feeling you get in your skin and
bones
cuz no man ever lived by bread alone you
need peaches and cream and a well
integrated approach to just abdicate
your trouble you a Decatur Rivas cuz
it's the summertime it's a time to take
it oh so easy now I'm not saying the
clothes don't count all that money don't
Yelp or the bread don't count but if we
all sat down to write our true
confessions we have to own up that we
don't own much possessions just a body
that's what we've all got more or less
but a popper can become a prince in
disguise fly through the air the way a
ccall flies like a bird like a plane
like Superman little practice flip of
the wrist compound fracture
a little meditation some contemplation
cuz it's a summer time it's a time to
take a nice and easy Soph a human body
is all that y'all come out to the beach
in the Sun near the phone if you want to
be self sufficient self dutiful you too
can build yourself a body beautiful get
healthy from your head to your toe nail
cuticle it's what the doctor ordered
it's therapeutic so come and take it
easy just take it slow and easy cuz out
it ma so beat you practice what they
preach to take it easy it's a clear day
it's any day in the summertime in the
summertime when you're out in the good
clean air again and the time clock ticks
on alone and you're through with your
week day care again and suddenly you
feel free of those nine-to-five working
blues and you're through Earth and Sun
all are yours it's a clear day just a
crazy day in the summer time
my son